for us and i can't speak for all venture
capital funds i think it's it's always
been the idea of how do we
create positive change in the world
through the investments that we make and
you know you have to think about this as
a very long time
uh
very long time process so we're looking
for those macro changes that would would
allow us to
do things completely differently this
exponential change exponential impact um
both financial impact obviously is a
venture capital firm but also human
impact of things that would drive big
changes in the world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
i am so incredibly excited for this
episode meet draw bellman the founding
partner at innovation endeavors which he
co-founded with eric schmidt
he invests in early-stage startups that
are driving exponential rates of change
in their industries leading to a super
evolution
draw has invested in over 100 different
companies from seed through series b he
led the firm's investments in uber sofi
planet zimergen frenome blue river
technologies and others before becoming
an investor he was a team leader of r d
at nice systems he earned an mba from
stanford graduate school of business and
a bachelor's of science in computer
science from ben gurion university he is
an ml7 associate at creative destruction
lab and a member of the steering
committee of israel collaboration
network welcome droll
dolberman welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you great thanks for having me
thanks for coming thank you so much for
inviting me to the i have to tell you
it's one of the most beautiful offices
i've seen hey we're in the middle of
palo alto and california avenue
overlooking stanford in one direction
with the beautiful trees the energy is
amazing
we're on the third floor right now
there's still a roof above us and
there's more offices downstairs
really just an inspiring location and i
think it fits for for the vision and the
mission that you're on with innovation
endeavors and that that you started 10
years ago with eric schmidt of course
and looking at the future in a bit of a
different light no tell me a little bit
about yourself and and what is ie
sure first of all thanks for having me
on the show i've been a great fan um big
fan since you started it and it's so
exciting to see how how much has been
done
over the last year uh on 20 minutes
later so thanks for having me on this on
this podcast
so um uh maybe a little bit about myself
i'm from israel originally as you as you
know by now
i
have a technology background growing up
i then moved to spend a few years on a
special forces side so i guess for a few
years i was a monkey that carried
technology on his back
and then concluded it was much better
actually to build stuff so i went back
to study computer science and
bioinformatics
i tried my life as an engineer for a few
years in israel before concluding i
wanted to do something slightly
different and ended up coming to get my
mba actually just across the street
literally across the street literally
cross street so it's uh
you know i came like everybody else uh
that comes to stanford i was uh it came
with the idea that i spent a couple of
years studying uh getting my mba in my
case and then maybe work for a couple of
years and then go back but
that never really worked out that way
you know we we ended up my wife and i
ended up uh
staying here it's been almost 15 years
wow
and three weeks later we're quite happy
uh it's been it's been a phenomenal
journey and a great adventure which was
really what i was looking for when i
came here right um
about a decade ago
i ended up partnering or meeting eric
schmidt who was one of my professors
stanford that was then the ceo of google
we started working together in 2009 and
in 2010
we got excited about this idea about
this uh uh
concept of what we call the super
evolution it just mentioned uh we
recognized at a time after having a lot
of the discussions that
the world was changing and it was
changing very very quickly and while we
were
accelerating technology in many
different ways and domains
these technology advances were not
necessarily
advancing a lot of the the problems that
were really important for us uh back
then but also as we hypothesized that
following would be important for us over
the next few decades we were looking at
some of the
the bigger things that we would need to
solve over the next 20 30 years anything
from
dealing with a much
bigger population and how do we feed
this uh this granulation thinking about
how do we accelerate uh
how do we accelerate uh the way we think
about life sciences both on the
therapeutic side as well as diagnostics
to deal with some of the pandemics that
we we knew back then that would sort of
come
back off and all
again and again that we would need to to
deal with
uh as well as thinking about climate
change obviously and things that we need
to do in order for us to um
live in a world that was uh uh was
livable i guess but i have a question
for you all you know everything that
you're just mentioning it's fascinating
and obviously these are things that we
need to be tackling
but sitting where you were 10 years ago
with eric
what was different then about the way
that you're approaching these problems
because these are problems that we hear
politicians talking about them and if we
ask what are the urging problems in the
world
what what is lacking still
in our industry as worth as we're
talking about these problems yeah i
think as we sort of spend a lot of time
thinking about those problems recognize
that one of the key issues that was
preventing us from solving those
problems was the
the innovation cycles that we were using
as as humanity to actually advance
innovation in those domains
um
essentially in a lot of those domains
you would have
you have a scientist or a group of
scientists that would work together come
up with hypotheses of what they wanted
to test what they wanted to do then
would essentially build this experiment
run it and then see what came back on
the other side and then use mostly use
the success of what worked rather than
everything that didn't work as well to
essentially design a next set of
experiments and obviously you're always
limited by the number of scientists that
you can have by the the amount of time
it takes around an experiment and so on
so everything was pretty serial and
incremental and slow and in some of
those industries that were very
important if you think about you know
the the life sciences world for example
it would time sometimes take decades to
actually get go through a step function
improvement to find something new right
and we'll take you know increasingly
actually over the last 10 years it's now
taking us uh twice the amount of time
and twice the amount of money to bring a
new drug to market wow so
we knew that if you forecast this into
the future this was just not sustainable
we couldn't really be in a place where
we we're not innovating quickly enough
to solve some of the problems
and
um
or the last year or the last year and a
half as much as they've been really hard
for all of us they've also been great in
a sense that it really highlighted a lot
of those things that need to be done
right i mean anything from
uh dealing with the pandemic of course
and and
having this need to come up with a
solution
in in
in months or weeks rather than you know
wait decades or wait you know a few
years until we have a vaccine place
right we had to innovate festive
um we all the folks that live here in
california
have all felt
uh the smoke that that came up as you
know we had huge fires around uh around
california it became an annual thing now
it's not just a one-off it was happening
every maybe every summer over the last
few years so
um you know everybody recognize that
this is this is uh things are different
we have to solve things now in a very
different way and we have to move faster
and maybe the last example there would
be um even cities and governments and we
think about citizen government making
decisions you know
obviously we all think about the slowest
moving entities in the world that need
to
take years or decades to react
over coffee they all understood that
they have to move within framework time
frameworks of sometimes 24 hours or even
less to actually react to something that
is going on and make a decision so
they're all increasingly looking for
ways to innovate faster make decision
faster and actually hopefully make the
right decisions as well
10 years 150 investments 20 unicorns and
you know if by looking at you know the
portfolio companies
i i get excited and and the reason i get
excited is because i'm looking you're
looking at vastly different industries
from agriculture tech like plenty and
afresh to we're looking at space
technology to satellite imagery to
autonomous fleet
to devsecops i mean really across the
spectrum but what the connecting dots
among all of them from my perspective is
this idea of looking at really bold
ideas
that are that if they work
are positioned to change the way we
think about this industry and now you've
raised you've announced your next fund
the 500 million dollar fund
and i love that first sentence that you
wrote on the medium post because that
sentence was i think
that we now have an if there's an
urgency to promote positive to promote
positive change right
and and that was really inspiring tell
me a little bit about you know why what
what is this urgency that you're feeling
now you mentioned this a little bit
before but in the context of the last 10
years as well
yeah i i think that um i've always been
an optimist and i think that my role as
an investor is to be an optimist right
so in spite of all those challenges we
talked about earlier
we recognized eric and i this is back in
2010 and since then that's the work
we've been we've been working towards is
that we can now
solve a lot of those problems we can now
start implementing or applying
technology
to actually move faster in a lot of
those domains
and
that that's sort of what kept me excited
about the role i've been doing is i can
actually i'm in a position now to help a
lot of those people who have those huge
visions and those big dreams to
essentially exercise those those dreams
and build those kind of companies that
change the world
and um what really made us
optim optimize at that time was this
idea of the super evolution right we
basically we came up with the thesis
that you know if you look at the
that um if you look at technology at
that time and even increasingly uh now
um
we were just really coming up to a space
where there was certain categories of
technologies that were emerging and
converging to allow us to move faster in
a lot of those uh markets that i
mentioned uh one of those was
instrumentation and data right the
ability to now
capture data
mostly in the physical increasingly also
in the biological world uh that was
really never captured before and capture
huge amounts of data in terms of sort of
anecdotal data we can now essentially
instrument almost every aspect of the
physical world and increasingly a lot of
different aspects of the biological
world such that we can understand what's
going on right the second thing was uh
computation and really having this
ability to now
take large amounts of data and run
compute on them whether it's in the
cloud or increasingly at the edge and if
you think about then i know you're an
expert in in ai and machine learning we
can now take all this data digest it and
infer insights and recommendations in a
way that was never possible before as
well so we can all you can do this now
maybe 100 x 1000x
better faster cheaper than even just you
know a few years ago and this was
groundbreaking at a time and even more
so is the case today
and then the third part was this idea of
engineering
advanced engineering the advances we
were seeing in engineering
both across automation
and robotics in the physical world but
also this idea that we could now
engineer the biological world so
essentially if you think about it in a
computer science context we could now
read process and write
back into the physical and biological
world in a way that wasn't possible
right before
and
for us what we recognized was this idea
that this allows us now to essentially
take those innovation circuits that i
talked about earlier
put them now in the context of
a completely new architecture we can
have machines at the center of the cycle
designing building and and testing
different hypotheses at a completely
different scale but also the fraction of
the time and cost right you're all used
to so we can now run fast and x
experiments or thousand x more
experiments in some of those industries
at one one thousandth of the cost in
time right so it can essentially
collapse time uh in in sort of the way
we innovate right and that was
groundbreaking concept for us because we
recognized that if you
now think about it and thinking about
this machine learning concept of
closed-loop planning where we can now
learn from all the different experiments
and also the 99 of accelerated learning
yeah exactly so this is now becoming
this idea that we can now uh grow in a
non-linear way and we call this concept
the super evolution exactly thinking
that we are gonna start seeing companies
that are gonna be
they're gonna be
moving at a pace that we've never seen
before and also industries that speaks
also to the thesis of saying you know
we're seeing all these amazing
technologies around us that are
incredible yet we're still in the
infancy of deep technology and where
we're going to be headed with with the
way technology advances it's there's
still so much room to grow
which i think is fascinating but well
one thing that i really want to
grab a piece of your mind at you know
the traditional venture capital model
we're seeing companies we're looking at
pain points that are happening we
evaluate the way that the companies the
companies is progressing towards their
goal their their sales metrics their
their engagement and we're trying to
estimate and project what's going to
happen in the next quarter and
month-over-month growth we hear that a
lot right
i'm getting the sense that you're not
looking as much of that as you are at
you know let's think down the line and
what does the company have to do in
years worth of time in terms of the
technology in order to bridge a bigger
pain point right it's a little bit of a
different model of thinking for a
venture capital uh fund
i mean i i think for us and i can't
speak for all venture capital funds i
think it's it's always been the idea of
how do we
create positive change in the world
through the investments that we make and
you know you have to think about this as
a very long time
uh
very long-term process so we're looking
for those macro changes that would would
allow us to
do things completely differently this
exponential change exponential impact
both financial impact obviously is a
venture capital firm but also
human impact of things that would drive
big changes in the world so we've been
less excited about
companies that
are consumer internet companies that are
changing you know incrementally becoming
the next facebook or twitter
or tech talk or whatever and sort of
more interested in how do we how do we
think about the new space industry right
what kind of things would be possible
now that those technologies are coming
to play
and we've had a lot of different um
conclusions i guess and maybe i'll try
to synthesize some of that and and you
know share my thinking about what do i
think the the next
decade would look like
to your point uh so few linux that we've
had over this period of time and how
we're thinking about this uh um
how we think about the future
so uh the first
insight with it is that you know the
the hypothesis that we have initiated i
said it's actually working and and
10 years ago for 10 years ago yes so
basically we're starting to see
it's working now uh it's in the sense
that uh
we're seeing companies that um
we're seeing big companies that have
been created in industries that even a
decade ago just over a decade ago have
been considered untouchable
um we're seeing that in companies
such as uber which one of our early
portfolio companies which is a great
example i think for a company that
completely changed the way we're
thinking about transportation right and
they've been working in an industry that
very few people thought at the time
would actually be you would be able to
change it right because of regulation
because of a million different things
and here you had the company that was
maybe one of the fastest growing
companies in history is it completely
changed the way we're thinking about
moving things around
um similarly with companies in the space
industry that i mentioned earlier so
thinking about planet one of our
companies just about to go public
that took a completely new approach to
the satellite industry right and again
this is a industry where satellites
would sometimes take
a decade to build would cost hundreds of
millions of dollars would be extremely
heavy you know way a few tons and so on
and thinking about what could be done
differently now and how do we change
this industry through a completely new
architecture of a satellite and they end
up building a much smaller satellite
much cheaper one so think about it so
that would cost maybe like an average
car
it would be this size roughly and we
would be able to build it within weeks
build and launch it within weeks
and here we are just a few years later
they now operate one of the the largest
fleets of satellite in the world they've
uh i think they've launched over 400
satellites during this period of time
they have 200 currently in orbit and
most interestingly they've built this um
capability through those imagery
satellites to now image the entire world
on a daily basis all right so completely
change the industry and not only that
both planet as well as uber have created
not only this this role model for a lot
of entrepreneurs that
they show them they can actually change
those industries that nobody wanted to
touch before but also that you can do it
you could do it at a
at a time frame that allow you to grow a
very big company through this sort of vc
industry
and they're creating this platform both
talent platforms but also technological
platforms that others can use now to
completely
uh change what they have done over the
last 10 years and do it faster than they
have done that as well right so we're
starting to see this uh
this exponential phenomena happening and
again for us it's just a great proof
that um
you can now change those industries you
can do it faster than everybody thought
and we think that actually over the next
decade we can do it even faster
what is common to the founders and this
is going to be a selfish question
because like you know one day i'm
looking to build a company or several
companies of my own and
you know when i'm looking at the
companies that you're backing i mean
those are the types of problems that i
as an entrepreneur want to wake up in
the morning for but i feel that it
requires a personality and it requires
us some way of thinking that is that is
a little bit different
what have you observed that has been
successful amongst your founders and
their way of thinking that and that it
make that enables them to go and pursue
these crazy
potential companies
yeah one one of the
conclusions that we've had over this
period of time is that those companies
that we
we've backed and that have been
successful
are different than most companies we've
done a decade before right so what we
are seeing there is that
uh the different sense that they usually
start with a mission and so the founders
are starting with a mission and the
mission is not to make a lot of money or
to build a big company the mission is to
solve a very big problem right the world
cares about right and i think
increasingly the world cares about
mission-driven companies because it does
allow you to recruit better talent does
allow you to attract certain kind of
investors and so on and so forth so i
think it was sort of uh one interesting
aspect of those founders that
we've seen is just start with a big
vision and it's usually sort of a
mission-driven vision
the second thing is that
um
that that we've seen with those
companies is that they tend to be
multi-disciplinary so it's not uh as
much of a single domain type of company
that you know if you want to start
facebook sure you have you know
understanding consumer indian company
there is a uh sentence certain type of
talent you would want to hire for this
company but if you're starting a new
company in the tech biospace for example
and you know take my company acorn
therapeutics for example
they had to assemble some of the the
best
uh people in the world across so many
different fields right you have
some of the best biologists and some of
the best uh chemists but also you have
some of the best computer scientists
uh roboticists you know mechanical
engineers and so on incredible all
coming together to
build a team that works and those teams
just tend to look very differently so
you sort of have to manage that kind of
complexity and the founders need to sign
up for that yeah and
what i think a lot of those founders
realized or saying the best founders to
point realize that
really the best way for you to do it is
to a come up with a mission so we need
to hire those people let's come up with
a mission that will attract these people
and i think increasingly
talent in a silicon valley and worldwide
is attracted to solve those kind of uh
uh to join those kind of mission-driven
companies they go beyond just stimulated
salary or when intellectually
stimulating environment they also want
to solve a big problem so they tend to
join
um
and also i think those founders tend to
hire the right kind of executives
earlier on so it's it's to sort of
manage that complexity so we see this uh
um
looking at some of my companies that
have really hired well you know it's
something that they tend to do
very quickly and they tend to do to hire
some of the best people in the world way
ahead of the time that they should hire
those people but they tend to get
they they can get them excited and they
have them join very early in the journey
was this always the plan for you
to look at the world
you know with the
wide lands five ten years ahead and and
be at the forefront of trying to solve
some of the most difficult problems like
you know if you look back at your army
days even at the gsb
is this who dwell was back then as well
i don't think so i think that um i was
always the type of person that was
curious
and
interested in the world and trying to
explore
uh you know since i was a kid and i
think about my military and sort of
other things i think i was always the
type that
pushed myself to
to the best i could so whether it was
the army unit that i did i chose whether
it's coming to the sort of the degraded
in bengali university or degraded in
stanford but i think it was really only
here at stanford when i when i went
through my mba
that
when i graduated i remember this was in
one of the courses when they we did a
sort of a synthesis class to sort of
synthesize a lot of the learnings that
we've had over the
the past couple of years at stanford
um
sort of came with the conclusion that
now at that time
i i
had different capabilities i've built my
capabilities to change the world maybe i
know it sounds
it's sort of maybe
audacious or naive or whatnot but sort
of feel like the work speaks for itself
given um
given that i was here given the amazing
amount of people and talent that was
here was possible right i saw the people
coming to my class and talking about the
companies they've been it's like i know
that different
than than me you know i could do all
those things and in some ways also felt
that i was
responsible to do that or it was my
responsibility to
actually step up and and
think about my life goal and think about
fulfillment and think about you know
what what would make me
fulfilled by the time i'm 90 or 100 or
or whatnot to just
think about the things that i've done so
i feel like i was responsible given that
i was taking maybe the place of somebody
else who could have been a central that
and would go out and do those kind of
things so i think that sort of put me on
trajectory to
understand the confidence and have the
sense of responsibility to pursue those
kind of big ideas and then
do you still have that weight on your
shoulder right now today you know one of
the leaders of innovation endeavors with
the incredible team that you have with
sam and harpy and scott and eric and
do you feel as you're walking down the
street or you're talking to your kids at
home and your wife
that you have a responsibility to
fulfill for the world
i do i feel like it's um
i think especially given that since then
i've had kids and and i can see
and talking about what we've experienced
here over the last year from cover to
the the horrible fires around here
i do feel that
i'm in an extremely fortunate position
to effect the change
and i think it
it's time to actually for all of us not
just me to think about how do we improve
the world and how do we live a better
place after us and again i'm an optimist
so i'm not
deterred by all these uh things that we
we're seeing around us and mostly
thinking about positive dates how do we
how do we do more and you know i'm i can
play a role in that by
uh catalyzing
more growth by catalyzing more startups
that or more visionary founders that
have the right idea and and
where i can partner with them or we can
partner with them as a team and support
them through this
process so i'm
i feel that that's
a responsibility but also to be honest
it's also fun it's not that i'm carrying
a big weight on my shoulders and and
sort of i feel sad about it i think it's
amazing i've been so excited to do what
i do
um i would say that it took me a long
time to understand if i'm actually good
at it and i'm still sort of getting it
out to be honest but it's um
it just you know it's been it's been a
fun
process and by now i feel like i have
more of a sense of where can i be
effective as an investor as a as
somebody who runs this firm and how do
we you know how do we build more and do
more of that but i'm really enjoying it
i mean the companies that i get to work
with are amazing uh and
i think this is an incredible job for
people who
like to work with a lot of different
things you know this is just i can start
my morning with a with one of my quantum
computing companies atom computing that
is completely changing the world and the
way we're thinking about uh
what we could do with compute
to acorn therapeutics where i'm spending
time with a nobel prize winner and
people who are building a super
resolution microscope that allow us to
understand biology in a completely
different way than we understand it
today so essentially uh looking into
really
looking into real living sales and see
the way potentials are moving engaging
with each other and build a drug
discovery company based on that all the
way to planet uh who just have it they
are just gonna make for them they're
celebrating ten years uh next week and
and again they've built an amazing
company
that
has now become one of the most important
satellite companies in the world but
they also held
the imagery that they created helped us
now
catch illegal deforestation activities
in different places around the world
illegal fishing activities and so on so
all those things are coming together to
for me just to see to be very
proud and very excited about what i'm
doing you know i'm looking at all these
all the examples that you're giving and
and many more portfolio companies that
are coming into mind
immediately and i think what's also
common to them is the fact that they're
not just doing one thing that the
they're developing some technology or
they're solving some pain point
the ripple effect is you can't even
imagine what's going to happen you're
mentioning a few use cases for planet or
for acorn or for atom computing but
really they're changing the way we
interact with technology and an
enablement for others to then go and use
that technology to continue affecting
positive change in their own domain and
i think that that that is just simply
incredible and uh i think that it's a
it's just a a really crazy privilege no
it's it's very true i mean all those
companies i mentioned essentially become
the platform for change for the next
generation of companies right right and
that's why we're so excited about the
next thing is because we recognize that
a lot of those as i mentioned uber and
planet some examples have now created
uh if not created technological
platforms for others to use you know
that that's one aspect they've shown
that this could be done
a lot of the technologies that i
mentioned earlier on instrumentation
compute and robotics are increasingly um
accelerating pace and sort of in a way
we we can do
completely different things that we
could do 10 years ago and i think of the
next scenarios the pace of change we
just increased so we're going to have
significantly better capabilities across
all those domains right and a lot of my
companies are actually creating these
kind of uh advances and then they share
it with the walls such that others can
build on them and so on and so forth
and then
i think that uh um
as you see more success you know those
become again platforms uh and role
models for a lot of other people who
want to start and do the same kind of
thing so
i'm incredibly
uh excited about what's to come
and again i think that the platform
we've built and the platform our
companies have built would allow us to
do so much more over the next decade so
that's awesome to the super evolution
thank you so much
this was amazing thank you for hosting
me here thank you for the inspiration
more more than anything uh you know the
when the post that you wrote about also
when i'm here about joining and
the the one the anecdotes about how
you're going on hikes and the you know
part of the inspiration that you're
gathering also is from the conversations
that you're having with those around you
talking about how how different
technologies are going to push change in
in our lives and and having that be just
an instrumental part of your daily life
and that's something that i use that i
wish for myself i can't think of a
greater privilege and more fulfillment
so thank you very very much thank you
yeah i would just say that um
it takes a village
so what i recognize early on is that as
much as i may be smart and i think
comparatively here i'm probably not very
smart
it's really you have some amazing people
around you that's really about the
people around you and i try to surround
myself with a lot of amazing people and
i'm i've been very lucky to
build this community that i like around
here and also in israel where i can
talk to a lot of very smart people
understand um
what they are seeing and how they view
the world because it's those people it's
a lot of times entrepreneurs that are
always really in there at the trenches
you know cutting edge of the network you
always step behind them by trying to
take all this information and see how do
we help them and what can we learn so we
can affect a better future i would also
say that eric schmidt has been an
amazing part of it as well you know from
his vantage point and the things that
they are seeing and he's seeing and
the way that he's
influencing us or or or encourages us to
pursue and and maybe double down on a
lot of that vision it's just been an
amazing opportunity for me personally to
to see all that and then synthesize all
that and then build innovation for us to
to keep investing and partnering with
entrepreneurs amazing
[Music]